tu vas voir leonard à cette nouvelle
recette que j'ai trouvé dans ce livre de
cuisine nous allons nous régaler tant
mieux tant mieux casimir très sain mais
une fin peut être le plus imaginer oui
mais seulement il ya il ya un petit
problème
évidemment ça m'aurait étonné explique
toi vite parce que quand je te disais ah
ouais tu as fait d'accord - tf1
et bien voilà il ya écrit là en bas
regarde les deux dernières petites
lignes cuire à feu très doux sinon c'est
raté
c'est dommage
tant bien je veux bien attendre un peu
mais que la recette soit vraiment une
réussite je veux vérifier s'ils ne me
manque rien alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
un kilo de riz bon je lai
1 kg de sel le sel d'accord
deux kilos de farine dur kg de farine
c'est ça ait du beurre
du beurre bah oui c'est ce que je dis du
beurre à nom du beurre
j'ai toujours dit du bar l'entregent
sais quoi qui m'a dit j'ai acheté du
du bea ça devait être une autre marque
c'est tout dans ce cas là il nous sommes
d'accord tu peux mettre du beurre si tu
veux et je ne vois pas où est la
difficulté enfin
bon enfin l'arrêt tous et toutes ces
discussions moi je n'arrose par un écran
si on ne peut plus participer
bon je vais faire une petite sieste et
rêvé que je mange je cherchais sacrée
bonne idée car comme dit le proverbe qui
dort dîne aux attentions casimir ne
prend pas ce proverbe comme excuse pour
oublier de me réveiller et tout manger
tout seul mais non enfin tranquille
léonard groupe mais non je ne suis pas
très très tranquille enfin je préfère
quand même dormir un peu
hâlé voilà c'est tout de même bizarre
que kazim biens ne soient pas encore là
si julie n'est pas encore très tard
tiens justement le voilà qui arrive
mes amis oui je suis très content de
vous trouver ici tous les deux car j'ai
un conseil très important à vous
demander à mes casimir c'est toujours
avec les îles de quoi s'agit-il eh bien
devinez julie rey cuisine évidemment de
cuisine écoute casimiro ce cas là je
crois qu'il vaut mieux que tu t'adresses
à julie mais pourquoi prend sens que tu
penses qu'à la cuisiner seulement la
sphère des filles toi on veut mais pas
du tout casimir avant tout non je pense
simplement que question cuisine julie
est beaucoup plus doués que moi bon
je t'écoute casimir voilà alors j'ai une
recette dans laquelle je veux remettre
du riz du safran des herbes 6 juin
apollo je t'arrête tout de suite casimir
tu mets d'abord l'eau tu l'as fait
bouillir que jette le risque seulement à
ce moment là ensuite tu rajoutes des
herbes et enfin julie arrête laisse moi
terminer enfin peu importe que je mette
d'abord lors îlots où le cerveau c'est
pas du tout ce que je te demande c'est
quand même curieux d'une demande d'un
conseiller tu ne m'écoutes même plat et
bien débrouille toi tout seul après tout
enfin julie les soins terminée
soit on va rire attaque mais
alors casimir ça se présente bien cette
recette main non pas du tout je ne sais
pas ce qu à julie aujourd'hui mais elle
est très désagréable
je crois qu'elle veut garder ses
recettes pour elles auront coûte que du
mur ce m'étonnerait beaucoup de julie tu
sais en fait si moi je peux te rendre
service peut-être peut-être voilà j'ai
une recette qui comporte du riz des
herbes du safran et 10 non stop stop
casimir je t'arrête tout de suite moi si
j'étais à ta place tu vois je commençais
par m quelques bonnes petites tomates
arrêt du meilleur ensuite des échalotes
et de l'ail haché menu menu menu
allemande morsi et après simplement tu
verses leur île en courant comme lui aïe
on les tue les montants neige et jacques
muller secours où ils écoutent même pas
il est parti c'est un petit peu fort
monsieur vient demander un renseignement
je lui donne il écoute n'aime pas la
réponse est bien sa recette ça promet
d'être bon
[Rires]
alors c'est moi le maire tremblay j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui je vais
enfin pourra faire une bonne affaire
avec ce gros balourd de casimir
julie m'a l'air de bien mauvaise humeur
c'est peut-être l'occasion de la mère de
mon côté aurait pu avoir
excellente amie excellente amie que
s'est il passé de santé lire sur votre
visage l'image même de la contrarier
aussi cela même monsieur travelling
figurez-vous que casimir est venu nous
demander un conseil à françois et à moi
et il nous a même pas écouté conseil
s'était pas adressé directement à moi
c'est curieux mon métier donner des
conseils aux artistes kazemi est un
artiste incomparable ne rien demander
sans doute n'at-il pas osé et dites moi
dites moi ce conseil quels sont les
sujets bien une recette de cuisine je ne
devrais pas vous le dire mais je crois
qu'il nous préparait une surprise
un succulent repas enfin qui devait
l'être au alors rien n'est perdu rien
n'est perdu je suis là pour lui prouver
qu'il peut compter sur
ses travellings et j'espère que vous
n'avez pas dans l'idée de mettre casimir
dans une cage comme mano river gros
montants feront foi françois comment on
pouvait voir une aussi mauvaise opinion
de moi mais non voyons je suis en
contrat pour sauver quasi mieux pour
l'aider dans sa nouvelle recette de
cuisine et bien pardonnez moi de vous
avoir soupçonné mais à propos de sa
recette de cuisine je suis très inquiet
oui certes casimir a l'habitude de
recettes de cuisine c'est étrange mais
aujourd'hui il n'a voulu écouter aucun
conseil attention le voilà qu'arrive
vous les gars sont pas
bons jours ou plus cobra bonjour alors
casimir toujours en plaindrait pas rater
ouais j'ai un ami vous êtes en homme
d'expérience vous avez beaucoup voyagé
vous allez donc pouvoir me conseiller
utilement me bien sûr la grande partie
voici deux mois que je cherche à vous
prouver que je suis là pour vous
conseiller tous et quel en est le sujet
art décoration
peinture sculpture art non non non non
il s'agit d'un cuisine la cuisine c'est
ma spéciale toutes les cuisines chinoise
anglaise
et moi écouter moi c'est une recette
très simple qui comporte du riz de l'eau
du safran des herbes et des zeks je me
sers mieux encore on tout de suite mais
il est déjà très important de savoir
s'il s'agit de henry non vérifiables
d'eau bouillie mont dolent source 9 du
jeu au delà venaient m'embrasser ou
enfin c'est pas déjà suffi après j'en ai
assez est ce que vous allez écouter ma
question jusqu'au bout oui ou non c'est
incroyable pendant ce temps mon pauvre
ami leonard meurent de faim chez moi
c'est vraiment inadmissible un pan du
mur écoute mon vieux d'une vingtaine pas
te mettre en colère on ne demande donc à
t'écouter au second tour tu voudrais pas
vous vexer c'est vrai bon alors voilà
c'est une recette très simple avec du
riz de l'eau déjà des herbes et du
safran et je voulais simplement savoir
si pour cela je devais prendre une
grande casserole
ou bien une très grande casserole c'est
tout
point final
je vous ai préparé un discours de quatre
pages
jeu je m'aperçois qu'il est déjà très
tard alors et je vais vous résumer mon
discours au revoir et revenez bientôt
nous voir